>> Sharon Horowitz:
Hi, good afternoon.
Welcome to the African and
Middle Eastern Reading Room.
On behalf of the
Geography and Map Division
and the Hebraic Section,
let me thank you
for coming to today's program.
My name is Sharon Horowitz.
I'm a reference librarian
in the Hebraic section.
The Hebraic section began, or
considers itself to have begun
in 1912 with the receipt
of 10,000 Hebrew
books and pamphlets.
Whose purchase was
made possible by a gift
from New York philanthropist
Jacob Schiff.
From those humble beginnings,
our collections have grown
to about 250,000 items.
In Hebrew, Yiddish,
Ladino, Judeo-Persian,
and other Hebraic
script languages.
The Hebraic section also
includes an important collection
of books in Geez, Amharic,
and Tigrinya, the languages
of Ethiopia, past and present.
Our section's holdings
are particularly strong
in the subject areas of
Bible, Rabbinics, Liturgy,
Hebrew Language and Literature,
Responsa, and Jewish History.
Two of our missions
in this division are
to publicize our collection
and to bring people
into the Library.
One way we accomplish this
is by holding lectures
and having programs such as the
one we are hosting here today.
And now, a word about
our speaker.
Professor Marcin
Wodzinski is a Professor
of Jewish History
and Literature.
And the Head of the
Department of Jewish Studies
at the University
of Wroc?aw, Poland.
The scope of his
academic interests range
from the social history of
Jews in the 19th Century.
To the history of
the Jews of Silesia.
Jewish material culture,
and especially the history
of Hasidism and Haskalah.
His publications include more
than 100 articles in English,
Polish, Hebrew, French,
and Czech.
He has written an co-authored
and edited many books.
And we are very honored to
have him speaking to us today
about his newest book.
The Historical Atlas
of Hasidism.
Professor Wodzinski's
interest in Jewish history
and culture began with
Jewish cemeteries.
He learned Hebrew so that
he could read the Jewish
and Hebrew inscriptions
on tombstones.
And he became fascinated by the
custom of Hasidic pilgrimages
to the graves of Hasidic rebbes.
His interest is not in the
writing of the great leaders.
But namely about the rank
and file of average Hasidim.
And how they understood the
teachings of their leaders.
Two items of business
before we begin.
Professor Wodzinski's
book is available
for sale after the program.
And he has graciously agreed
to sign for anyone who'd like.
And also Michael
Klein of the Geography
and Map Division has prepared
a small display of interesting
and relevant maps related
to today's program.
And they're on display
in our division's
conference room behind me.
So please join us there
after the lecture.
This event is being videotaped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There'll be a formal question
and answer period
after the lecture.
At which the audience
is encouraged
to ask questions
and offer comments.
But please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the
question and answer period,
you are consenting to the
Library's possible reproduction
and transmission
of your remarks.
And now, please join me in
welcoming Professor Wodzinski.
[ Applause ]
>> Marcin Wodzinski:
Thank you very much.
Thank you for inviting me here.
Thank you for coming.
I'm very happy to be here.
Before I begin, let me
start with two comments.
First of all, I was
very happy to.
I was very happy to hear
about those 10,000 books
with which it, it began.
Because my departmental
library has 10,000 books now.
So maybe one day we will
be as great as this place.
And second of all, I am
not sure you've noticed.
But I'll be speaking about
geography of Hasidism straight
under the name of
Moses Mendelssohn.
I'm not sure that, that
[inaudible] will stand it.
But let's hope it won't
fall on our heads.
[Laughter] And now, I believe
that all we here believe
in the importance of Hasidism.
That is gathers us
here for the reason
that we recognize the
importance of the movement.
And this might be for many
different importances.
For some this is because
of the ideology issue.
Or identity issue or
the [inaudible] issue.
For some other it might
be anti-Hasidic sentiments
or some others might be
so-called threat of Hasidism.
To contemporary Jewish
life as some say.
So many reasons, but Hasidism is
indeed recognized today as one
of the most important
Jewish phenomena worldwide.
And it actually captured
international attention far more
than any other Jewish
phenomenon.
To give three examples.
In Orlando, Florida, in
Disney World, there is, ex--
exhibition about
nations of the world.
Israelis are not represented
by soldiers in uniform
or [inaudible] working
in kibbutz.
They're represented
by Hasidic couple.
The Hasidim who make
a small minority
of Israeli population today
are taken to be representative.
To be embodiment of
what it is to be Israeli
or Jewish more generally.
The saying in circles
in Moscow, there is a,
there is a performance,
Nations of the World.
Different animals
dressing in different garb.
Two monkeys in Hasidic
dress also representing,
representing what is Jewishness.
But maybe most spectacular is
case from Poland from Lublin,
the town of well-known
Hasidic leader [inaudible],
the Seer of Lublin.
When several years ago,
City of Lublin was looking
for a visual representation
of its 700 years of existence.
That want to have kind
of cis-- visual icon.
They make a competition.
And the project that
won is entitled,
"The Eye of the Tzaddik ."
And this is important.
This is the Tzaddik Horowitz,
the Seer of the, of the Lublin
who apparently, according to
tradition, could see from end
of the world to another.
But he is taken to
be representative
of not of Jewish Lublin.
Of all the periods.
He is taken to be representative
of Lublin as such.
And today, you have the
Eye of Horowitz of Lublin
on every [inaudible],
on every bath,
on every city announcement,
everywhere you have
[inaudible] everything around.
And mind you, this is
in the city of Lublin
which for all medieval and
early modern period was the town
of [inaudible].
That did not allow Jews
to live within its walls.
And now not just a Jew, the
Hasidic Jew is the repre--
is the symbol of this town.
I think this, this properly
captures importance of Hasidism
for Jewish and even more
so non-Jewish world today.
As something is taken to be
representation of Jewishness
or at least traditional
Jewishness.
And at the same time, as
I come to study Hasidism,
I to my surprise realized.
That much of what
we believe we know
about Hasidism is
informed by stereotypes.
Hasidic, anti-Hasidic,
and non-Hasidic ambivalent
stereotypes.
But these are clichés
that blind both popular
and academic research
into Hasidism.
From understanding
of what really shapes
and real phenomenon of Hasidism.
Two images that I brought to
your attention on the left.
This is well-known portrait
of the founder of Hasidism,
Baal Shem Tov which is
not the Baal Shem Tov.
This is a portrait, this
is well-known story.
This is a portrait of
Baal Shem of London,
not Baal Shem Tov from Poland.
But this image circulates
worldwide as the image
of the founder, right?
This is, well, this is at
least a stereotype that many
of us know is not true.
Second of that you put, that I,
that I put in there
on the right side.
This is what Hasidism really is.
And for many people,
this image of something
like in Masonic Lodge, maybe.
A sectarian group meeting
somewhere in hiding.
To do their secretive customs.
Is a dominant image of Hasidism.
Which emerges actually
from late 18--
and early 19th Century,
anti-Hasidic debates.
And of accusing Hasidism
of being a sect.
This sectarian terminology so
strongly sticks to Hasidism
that it blinds people
from understanding
Hasidism is not a sect.
And also if we say a sect
is sociological terms.
It could be kind of neutral way
of describing the
structure of the movement.
But obviously-- [phone ringing].
It's not mine.
If, if, if I may say, you
know when Messiah comes
or comes back for somes.
It will, the first thing he will
say is, "Turn off your mobiles."
[Laughter] And okay, now, now
coming back to now to Hasidism.
The term of sectarian
or sect contains much
of Christian debate around this
sect, and it's not neutral.
It's not descriptive.
It's the label denigrating the
phenomenon which is insinuating.
That categories that
do not belong
to the [inaudible]
really secretiveness,
closed-mindedness,
subjugation to the leaders.
And all other things that
we imagine about Hasidism.
By hearing the term
of sect of Hasidim.
Freeing from this category I
think is critical to understand
that Hasidism was something
far closer to confraternity
or hevrah, brotherhood.
And there were many
other brotherhoods
in Jewish communities in 18--
, 19-- , early 20 Century.
Than to a sectarian structure.
If we think about
Hasidism this way,
then immediately we
understand that the boundary.
Social boundary between
being Hasid
and non-Hasid was much lower.
And they don't function the
way we very often imagine.
We have hundreds of
articles who have tons
of books describing
world of Eastern Europe
in binary oppositional
terms of Hasidim and others.
And I'm claiming these
categories are not true.
Coming from these stereotypes,
the atlas that I'm discussing
today is focusing more
on spatial stereotypes
that many of us share.
It comes from certain concept
of Judaism that is popular.
And most widely, thanks
to an ex-Hasidic figure
of Abraham Joshua Heschel.
Who is famously claiming that
Judaism is religion of time
and not religion of space.
All the examples he was
giving for this came actually
from Hasidic tradition.
And he was applying the
[inaudible] even more
than anything else as such
a phenomenon that is rooted
in time and not in space.
Half a meter above the ground,
as you saw in previous slide.
And actually this concept
got circulation especially
after the Holocaust
for obvious reasons.
When centers of Jewish life.
Centers of studying of Hasidism
moved from Eastern Europe
to Palestine and
Israel later on.
To United States and Canada.
And places very far from
actual physical locations
of where Hasidism
once developed.
And it was very easy
for scholars of Hasidism
to ignore where [inaudible] is.
Because we could not find
[inaudible] on any map
because no such a place
exists on any maps.
It's Gora Kalwaria.
Right? And it's very
easy to ignore difference
between Ukrainian Bratslav
of [inaudible] of Bratslav.
And the German of Breslau,
[foreign language] for example.
Because for some Brelaus
and Bratslav is the
same, essentially.
And actually have
written article
that confused those two places.
So I say it's critical to get
to understanding those
kinds of essentials.
And this is one of few relative
advantages of being marginal
for myself being from Eastern
Europe and studying Hasidism is
that I'm closer to
those spatial, physical,
and social essentials
of getting to Hasidism.
What I would like
to present to you.
Depending on how much time I
will have will be two or three
of those stereotypes that
I think are very important.
And, and too predominant.
First of them you
see on the slide.
A so-called Hasidic
conquest of Eastern Europe.
The Hasidim march,
marching in their thousands
to conquer town-by-town and
turn it into Hasidic stronghold.
Where do we know it from?
Of course all we know is that
Eastern Europe was Hasidic when?
How much? To what, what extent?
Well everybody eventually
refers to page six in book
by Shimon Dubnow, titled
[inaudible] which is saying
by 1800, all of Eastern
Europe, with exception
of [inaudible] was Hasidic.
Okay. So my question is
where did you take
it from, Mr. Dubnow?
And then Dubnow give references
to [inaudible] political
literature saying
in late 18-- , early 19 century.
"Beware! Hasidim like a pest.
They are spreading over.
Be careful not to allow
them to come to your town."
Okay, but are we really
believing in, in hyperbole
to capture reality or to
influence reality, rather?
Obviously that function
of political text
by the [inaudible] was different
than to give proper description
of demographic trend
of Hasidism.
So my question is how can we
come to mapping the phenomenon
of this trend of Hasidism?
The idea would be to
have all the Hasidim
from late 18th century to
the Holocaust where they live
and how many they were.
And to make this up, but not
such a map can ever exist
because there are no membership
lists for Hasidimists, you know.
Instead, if we have any maps
of Hasidism, all they start
with mapping important
[inaudible].
Several map of this kind exist.
My problem is with
both categories.
One with what it covers
and what is important.
First of all, if
you map on one sheet
of map all the important
[inaudible] then you have
[inaudible] active
in mid-18th century.
And [inaudible] active
in 1930s on the same map.
This is as if mapping
American life of the Civil War
and today on the same map.
It wouldn't give reality.
This is blurring development.
It's blurring the fact
that in mid-18th century,
Hasidism was nascent.
And in the mid-19th century,
it was huge first
in Eastern Europe.
So instead of mapping
[inaudible] all in one map.
I suggested divide
it into five periods
and do it slice by slice.
And second suggestion.
If I would be satisfied
with category of [inaudible]
and this you can
obviously understand.
Who's important?
How we evaluate?
Is, is [inaudible] important?
He wrote important
book that many people
in 20th century study.
Was he important then?
Back in the 19th century?
What we make importance
of [inaudible].
Was important for
people around him?
He was maybe minor figure.
He was important Hasidic writer.
But it's very difficult
to make any sense,
especially for cartography,
of a category of importance.
So my simple response is it's
not important [inaudible]
of all of them.
It's ambitious because
obviously we don't know all
of the [inaudible].
But fortunately, Hasidism's a
culture of memory, very much so.
And commemor-- remembering
and commemorating Hasidic
leaders is important aspect
of Hasidic religious life.
For this reason, Hasidic
communal memory preserves huge
numbers of those.
After going through three
volumes of Hasidic encyclopedia
which was actually biographies
of several hundreds
of tzaddikim.
We meaning [inaudible]
and myself
who made this set of maps.
We came to number of
1,787 tzaddikim active
in Eastern Europe from
the [foreign language]
up to the Holocaust.
And we divided those tzaddikim
into where they lived
exactly, in which places.
And the periods they live.
And out of this comes five maps.
This is chapter 2-1
in the atlas.
That you will see in a minute.
That give totally different
image than the Hasidic conquest
of Eastern Europe by 1800.
First map is 1740 to 1772.
And what you see on
this map is essentially
that you don't see much.
Few dots. The dot
is the place of life
of a tzaddik, of Hasidic leader.
The bigger dot, the
bigger number of tzaddikim.
Here we have one or two
or three tzaddikim leading
in a place, right?
And all of them in
area of Podolia.
I, I have to say
here, do we have a way
to show it on the screen?
Yes? Podolia and Volhynia.
Very few of them in
[inaudible] to become Galicia.
Southern Belarus,
Central Poland.
There are very few dots.
Very few Hasidic
leaders at that time.
If we move to the next
period, 1772 to 1815.
Which according to
Dubnow, all this area
of Eastern Europe
was Hasidic already.
We have visibly higher
number of Hasidic leaders.
But we have also huge areas
not covered by the dots at all.
So we first of all see that
instead of Podolia here.
It is more Volhynia in this area
that is becoming more Hasidic.
And there's very significant
move northward and westward
of Hasidic leadership because
the main principle area
for Hasidic leadership today,
that period, is Galicia.
Here. And southern
parts of central Poland.
But look at northern
part of central Poland.
Look on Belarus.
Look on Lithuania.
There is none.
So this is obviously
not the high point
of Hasidic conquest
of Eastern Europe.
And this is 1815, right?
Fifteen laters that
Dubnow would put his point.
This is 1815 to 1867.
And I say this is a
remarkable change.
Somebody compared to a rush.
But I think it was a
hostile approach to Hasidism.
It's obviously showing huge
advancement of the numbers
and also territorial expansion
of Hasidic leadership.
The assumption behind
this [inaudible] I need
to mention here is kind of
trivial, it seems to me.
That the number of
leaders roughly corresponds
to the number of followers.
And that the places
of the residence
of leaders roughly
correspond to the places
of residence of their followers.
It's not always the case.
There are many exceptions that
I, we can go into listing.
But the general rule
for macro image
that I'm presenting
now is very correct.
So what we have here is
farther shift to the west.
Farther strengthening of Galicia
and southern part
of central Poland.
And first Hasidic leaders
appearing in territory
of Hungary and Romanian
territories.
So we for the first time
in mid-19th century.
Hasidic leadership crosses the
border of former [inaudible]
to go southward of
this territory.
Alright? So this is,
so this is happening.
This is possibly, if we compare
number of leaders to the number
of Jews living in
those territories,
mid-19th century is the peak
of Hasidic infiltration
of Eastern Europe.
The peak of their influence.
In some areas, like in Galicia,
it is obviously higher than 50%
of Jews in Galicia
being Hasidic.
With some areas they are
nearly totally Hasidic
like central part of Galicia.
And some others that
are significantly less.
So this is, so this is
a case of, of Galicia,
mid to late 19th century
Galicia as the peak.
Not 18-- , 1800, right?
And yet another map:
1867 to 18-- to 1914.
You see essentially the
same pattern as before.
But simply far bigger numbers.
Those numbers correspond.
They're bigger, but they
correspond to the huge increase
of number of Jews living
in these territories.
Because this is the time of very
dramatic demographical increase.
So relative numbers are
not higher than before.
Though obviously we see
a strengthening of the,
of the Hasidic leadership.
And we see also very
nicely territories
where Hasidic leadership
appears.
And where there are
no Hasidic leaders,
i.e. there are no Hasidim there.
And final map may
be most surprising.
Is the interval.
And what we see here is most
powerful Galician settlement
that you have still.
Which is this appearance
of Hasidic leadership
from eastern territories.
Here. very few Hasidic
leaders here.
And this is obviously an
outcome of the pogroms
of the First World War.
But even more so of Soviet
anti-religious policy
that is actually combatting
all forms of religious life.
And especially as
visible as [inaudible].
Being Hasid was very
strong expression
of religious identity.
Not only their [inaudible]
but also in dress.
In outside look.
So the Hasidic leadership was
the first to, to be persecuted.
And second phenomenon that
you, that you see in this map.
Is amazing concentration
in metropolis.
Something that we
had not before.
Here it is worse.
So [inaudible], Vienne,
[inaudible] and other
big cities.
The phenomenon did
not exist before.
And this, there are several,
several factors leading
Hasidism to what it is there.
First of them is
the First World War.
Today people tend
to forget about it,
especially that the Holocaust
overshadows importance
of the First World War.
But if you look on this picture,
this is not the Warsaw
ghetto, right?
Though it looks so.
This is the city of the town of
[inaudible] on Russo-Galicio,
on the Russo-Austrian
border in eastern Galicia.
As, as [inaudible] was
describing [inaudible].
This was a very prosperous
town leading
from this border location.
Having 700 homes.
In 1914, right after the
war begin, 23 remained.
The city was simply pulled down.
One of few buildings standing
there was a famous Hasidic
synagogue of the [inaudible].
Of the famous [inaudible].
Who escaped to Vienna as many
dozens other Hasidic leaders
escaping and abandoning.
And many of them
abandoning Galicia,
abandoning territories of war.
Many of them did not return
to Galicia after the war
because in [inaudible] there
was no life after the war.
Also because the
city still exists
but it was all burned down.
[Inaudible] returned
to his place in 1924.
And actually does a
very conscious attempt
at rebuilding nonexisting town.
And this is widespread
phenomenon.
Many of those who did
not escape to Vienna,
they escaped to other
large towns.
Because living in small
towns was very dangerous.
Because the first
population to be exposed
to atrocities of the war.
To extractions to, to
looting were people living
in small communities.
Because they were the easiest
victim for armies, for looters.
For whoever would
pass the place.
So a lot of Hasidic leadership
is moving to big cities.
And remains there after the war.
You have the map
of Hasidic leaders.
It's around 80 Hasidic leaders
and their movement
during First World War.
And what you see here is
essentially that overnight,
Vienna is becoming the
epitome of [inaudible].
You have like, like 40 Hasidic
leaders suddenly moving from all
over eastern Galicia and
Volhynia and coming to Vienna.
And you have, and you have
every second Galician Jew
at that time is escaping
to Vienna.
I [inaudible] imagine.
So this is huge mass of, of,
of refugees, refugees of war.
Settling there and turning
Vienna into the center, right?
The same to a smaller scale
is happening in Warsaw.
Though this is not
outside of the Warsaw.
This is actually the big
metropoly into which tzaddikim
from small places escape.
The same you have
later on in Kiev.
And this is something that is,
that has tremendous importance.
Not only for physical structure.
In a sense where a Hasid is
traveling to his Hasidic leader.
It has tremendous
importance also
for spiritual life of Hasidism.
Because the fact that up
to the First World War,
tzaddikim were living in small
towns was not accidental.
There was obvious choice.
Several of the tzaddikim
did live in bigger towns
like [inaudible] but it
was always commented.
It was something exceptional
that there must have
been a reason to this.
And it was given
in Hasidic stories
that the [inaudible] was leading
the Warsaw for certain reason.
And he left Warsaw because it
was impossible for the Hasidic
to live in sort of big city.
Now it changes.
Why tzaddikim were
living in small towns?
Because a small town was a place
at which Hasidic court
could establish its ritual
of being separated
from normal life.
You had to go on one or two
or three days', three,
not the three.
The pilgrimage to
get there, right?
You had to wait at the gates
of the court to get accepted.
You had to wait for
the visit to the rebbe
and the visits were very
often at all this time
of night, two AM, four AM.
To make it into something
special.
This is not part of
your daily routine.
This is something special,
this is something sacred.
That is how Hasidic
courts functioned.
And now try to imagine you,
your rebbe, [inaudible] here.
You meet him on the stroll
of the city of Warsaw.
He's just marching somewhere.
This distance between the leader
and the follower is
disappearing suddenly.
The bubble breaks.
And you can imagine
you have three rebbes
in the same tenement
house as you do.
So what you do, you
start hopping.
There is a phenomenon that
today is the sociology
of religion called
that [inaudible] Hasidism
religion a la carte.
And I say Hasidism
a la carte emerges
as a huge phenomenon during
the First World War and after.
We have memory memoirs
testifying to the fact
that Hasidim are not so much
Hasidim of the rebbe anymore.
They are Hasidim in
more general sense.
They come to one rebbe once,
to another rebbe for
another occasion.
This one is nicely singing
so we go to sing with him.
The other is giving
better sermons.
So we go to listen
to his sermon.
The other one is a miracle
maker, so we go to him
for a miracle if we need a
miracle at this occasion, right?
So this changes entirely
the structure
of spiritual interaction
between leader and follower.
And this is what I believe
you can read from those maps.
And then with the information
that the maps provide,
you get back to narrative
sources
which give you plenty
of this information.
The rebbe on the slide is
[foreign language] one of the,
actually the last Hasidic leader
to leave Soviet Union in '64
when he was, he was
freed from exile.
And so this is, so this
is a huge phenomenon
that is changing Hasidism
and more importantly,
I say that what we know
as Hasidism today is
to a big extent, an
outcome of this change.
Of things that happened
during First World War.
What we have as metropolitan
Hasidic leadership happens
exactly then.
What we see as the development
of modern [foreign language],
it happens exactly
there as a change
in ideologies of Hasidism.
It's happening exactly there.
The interwar period
creates structures
of contemporary Hasidism.
Obviously the Holocaust ends
Hasidism in Eastern Europe
and makes this new reappearance
in Palestine and North America,
Israel and North America.
So this is obviously
another turning point.
But if we think
about institutional way
how Hasidism functions.
Most of the changes happened
before the Holocaust.
They are not the
outcome of the Holocaust.
And I think this is very
important to understand
where contemporary
Hasidism comes from.
Another concept that I would
like to ask is how Hasidic
leadership functions.
And this is again
rooted in a stereotype
of you know this
heavenly leader.
Somewhere above the
heads doing things.
But we know very little actually
about the interaction
of the two.
Even if he was the
celestial leader.
Being you know that,
that, that, that channel
between the heavenly
bounty and us here.
He is bringing the blessing
of the God, of, of God to us.
It's obviously the
actual relations
that I wanted to study.
And this I believe can be
approached only if we realize
that in that golden period of
Hasidism, from late 18th century
up to the Holocaust,
the vast majority
of the Hasidim did
live at the court.
And very often they did not
live close to the court.
They had to travel to him.
The vast majority of their
religious life was happening not
at the court.
Not with the rebbe,
with the tzaddik.
It was happening
in their relation
within their communities,
within their shtiebel.
In their prayer houses.
And the prayer house seems
to me so far totally ignored
as a prime site of
the development
of Hasidic religious life.
How did it look like?
What were the ceremonies?
What were some of structures?
What was the experience
of being Hasidic there?
Not at the court.
And the map, chapter five speaks
about prayer houses, shtiebel.
This is, this is
beautiful picture.
I'm not sure you
can see it clearly.
Because this picture
was exposed twice.
One, there is a space, and
then you have figures here
who look like ghosts there.
I feel it's very telling because
this is a picture shortly before
the Holocaust.
So those people are disappearing
from this shtiebel very soon.
This is [inaudible] in Volhynia.
Now what I managed to do, and
this is I believe a good example
of why in my humble opinion,
atlas is the best response
to the questions I ask.
Is to map it through
not qualitative.
But not sort of [inaudible]
but quantitative approach.
Maps are a marvelous
research tool today
because with the advent
of digital humanities,
they allow us to do things that
were not available to us before.
We can process amount of data
that our minds would
not make sense of.
So for this map, I managed to
gather in variety of sources.
Information on nearly
3000 Hasidic shtiebel
in Eastern Europe
between 1900 and 1939.
It was quite a work.
I would say 12-years' project
to get to have all of them.
But once I get them,
with traditional tools,
I would get nowhere.
Because I could not understand
what was the pattern behind it.
By putting this into
databases and processing it
with so-called GIS, geographical
information system tools.
We can come to seeing the map
as the endpoint of the research.
But as a start point.
I did a series of maps that show
me different patterns emerging
from this data.
By different questions I can ask
by combination of
[inaudible] keys.
And from this, I start my
analysis how Hasidic life can
be understood.
Thanks to getting into this
information about their shtiebel
and how it's structured.
So first information that comes
from here that you see on those.
Is how Hasidic leader--
how Hasidic hierarchies
intra-Hasidic hierarchies
looked like.
In pre-Holocaust Eastern Europe.
Which groups dominated
in which territories,
and which were smaller.
If you, if you take for example
central Poland, this territory,
you know that 22% of all
shtiebel were Gerrer.
Ger was the dominant group.
It was followed by 12% of
Alexander, followed by--
[ Foreign Language ]
Which is not Polish court.
And on and on.
Once you get this data, you
immediately understand what is
about the conflict
between Ger and Alexander.
We have a lot of
narrative sources about it.
But we know very
little how it emerges.
It's not, it's nothing
personal, I say.
It's simply structural.
These are two dominant
groups competing
for dominance in territory.
And this is replicated
in Galicia.
In Galicia, you have what?
You have Belz and then you have
[foreign language] followed
by [foreign language],
Bobov and others.
So you have another well-known
case of [foreign language]
as the conflict for leadership.
You understand the structures
within Hasidic world,
explaining to you how
the structures look.
But this can go much farther.
I will not show you many
maps of this chapter
because we have no
time for this.
But this is one of them.
By dividing Eastern
Europe into squares of 35
by 35 kilometers each.
Which roughly gives
the, the, the, the,
the footage of an average
district in Europe.
I counted all the shtiebel
in each of those quarters.
I did not count it myself
with a pen, you know that,
that the software did it to me.
But it was, it was
possible to count for each
of those squares what
is the dominant group.
And what emerges out of
this is very clear map
of which Hasidic groups
dominate which areas.
It's not kind of
general central Poland.
You can very clearly see
that Ger is dominating center
and eastern part
of central Poland.
But it's not dominating
all of the western out,
outreach because this is
a territory for Alexander.
You beautifully understand that
the dominant Galician group
of Belz is not dominant
in all of Galicia.
This is a, the green here.
It's dominant only in
central part of Galicia.
And if you move west, you
have [inaudible] Bobov.
If you, if you move east, you
have [inaudible] an offshoot
of [inaudible] dominated there.
So you get into much
deeper knowledge.
With this you can even get
to understanding the
spiritual relation
between tzaddik and followers.
Because once I calculated, I
cannot talk about it, sorry.
Once I calculated relation
between the size of group
and distance between the
court and the shtiebel,
then you realize there is
very consistent correlation
between those two.
And you can establish
kind of typology of course
by their distances
and size of the group.
And it's not only physical.
This is about the
type of leadership.
Because very naturally for the
big Hasidic group, say Ger.
Which has been mentioned
already.
If Ger was in [inaudible]
of Poland,
apparently having
100,000 followers
which is obviously
inflated number.
But obviously tens of
thousands of followers.
And then average distance
between the court and the,
and the shtiebel was
something like 150 kilometers.
It's very ob-- very obvious
that the vast majority
of Ger Hasidim never
saw their leader.
If they came to the
court once a year,
or maybe not even once a year.
They were together with ten
or 20,000 other followers.
And they could not get
close to the rebbe.
It was more like the
soccer match than,
than a religious
experience of being close
to your intimate guide.
Because well, if you're wealthy.
If you were important,
if you were learned,
you obviously get
close to the leader.
But for average rank
and file Hasid,
and I'm interested in them.
It was very far.
Then you understand
that those courts had
to develop alternative forms
of religious affiliation.
On the other hand, you
have courts like Bobov
which in absolute numbers is a
small court in the [inaudible].
It's less than one percent
of the shtiebel belonging
to Belz, to, to Bobov.
Less than one percent.
Even in Galicia, it's
less than four percent
of the shtiebel that are Bobov.
But if you go into the
westernmost part of Galicia
into [inaudible] then you
have 16% of them being Bobov,
and this is the dominant group.
Because all others are smaller.
There are areas, districts
in westernmost part
of Galicia where, where
Bobov is more than 50%.
What does this say?
Bobov is less successful
than Belz?
No, it established
different relation
between the leader
and followers.
For Bobov rebbe and Bobov
Hasidim, it is more important
to be in a group of big
cohesiveness to be close.
To be recognized at the court.
To be able to travel there.
That's different type of,
of religious [inaudible].
Different charismatic
leadership.
Distant charismatic leadership.
And close charismatic leadership
that different groups display.
And this is again,
this is confirmed
in our [inaudible] sources.
If you go to Pintchiv
for example,
you read that the Pintchiv
was very proud of knowing all
of his Hasidim by name.
He knew all of them.
He knew all their problems, the
[inaudible] were coming to him.
They were close to him,
and he was close to them.
And they appreciated.
But this was very small
group at the same time.
Should we say Pintchiv was
less successful than Bobov?
I say no. This is
simply different model
of religious leadership.
And this you get again
from maps and from numbers.
And of which I believe
for many is surprising.
Okay, so coming to the
final section that I would
like to speak for a little.
We had still ten minutes, right?
This is the picture taken
of the [inaudible] rebbe at,
at Auschwitz, just before
he goes to the gas chamber.
And the obviously turning
point in my history
in what I present
is the Holocaust.
And I'm mapping the way to
death of many Hasidic leaders.
It's 80 Hasidic leaders that
I mapped on this map to show
where Eastern European
Hasidism dies.
And it is nothing surprising.
You see that the major
place for death of Hasidic--
of tzaddikim came from
Hungary is Auschwitz.
You see that mostly for Hasidim
from central Poland is Warsaw
ghetto and then Treblinka.
You see the places that,
that, that we know.
But I think it's very
important to map it.
Not only to know
it, but to prove it.
How it looks.
So and is very important to me,
this is very important
chart to, to show death.
But also to show resurrection.
Because after chapter seven,
there's chapter eight.
And we have it beginning
with this picture
of young Hasidic boys
in [foreign language].
Boys, not girls because girls
don't go out so easily, right?
Which is another topic
which appears in atlas.
The gender issue.
But my question, my
most essential question
that I ask not these boys.
But I ask in chapter
eight, in chapter leading
with contemporary post-war.
And Contemporary
Hasidism is again, as,
as you could realize so far.
I like simple question
and simple answers.
So the simplest question to
ask that I heard many times.
And possibly some of you
asked this question already.
Is how many there are.
How many Hasidim
there are today?
And I would say this was
to my biggest surprise
that sociologists say
no, it's too difficult
to answer this question.
It's always too difficult to
answer any question, obviously.
It doesn't mean we
should not try to do it.
And obviously there are good
studies trying to, to, to, to,
to answer this question.
There is beautiful article
that is based on census polls
and combining this with
different information.
It is trying to do it for United
States and there are other ways
that people are trying
to use school records.
Political data on voting to kind
of extrapolate the
rough number of Hasidim.
There are researched into
the [inaudible] of Hasidism
for individual locations.
Like Williamsburg, often
gives you groups like Belz.
But we don't have
an overall picture.
And I think this overall
picture is very important.
For anybody interested
in Hasidism.
And especially for those who
preach about Hasidic conquest
of contemporary Jewry.
And because after all, we
need to know if it's true.
And how far it is true,
or how far it is not.
So after some investigation.
I realized there are
indeed even today,
there are not Hasidic
membership lists.
This would be best, right?
To have the, you
know one unified list
of all the Hasidim worldwide.
And to map them.
Unfortunately, not.
But there are very close
substitutes to this.
Every big and [inaudible]
number of small, mid-size,
and small Hasidic groups.
Every couple of years
issues a telephone directory
for this specific group.
And these books function very
often like membership lists.
They are with few exceptions,
they are very reliable
because obviously each group
wants to include everybody.
It's important to
be in the book.
If you are not in the book,
it might cause troubles.
You might be not
[inaudible] and one of us.
And it is also important
that those groups want,
want to prove their
demographical size
because it's important
factor, right?
If you have mayor of New
York coming to you as a rebbe
to beg for your votes.
You say, "See telephone
book of my group.
It's, it is big.
I can give you those votes,
and you give me relative
value for this," right?
So this size is important
for the group.
On the other hand, there
is very clear protection
from inflating these numbers.
And actually there were,
there was several years ago
this interesting debate.
Within Hasidic [inaudible]
about one [inaudible]
against other [inaudible]
stealing claims.
Because they wanted
to show bigger.
And the other one was protecting
them for the same reasons
that the groups want
to keep it appropriate.
They don't want the
others to, to come victor
on the basis of fake
data, right?
So those data are very reliable.
I, I confronted those numbers
with a number of those.
And I, I came into possession of
44 either telephone directories
or substitutes for
telephone directories.
Which small groups,
there's no need
to issue telephone directory.
They have just Excel
sheet they are sending
to all the folk within them.
So that was essentially
the easiest.
Because somebody could, from the
group would just send it to me.
With telephone books, I had
to find a Hasidic friend
or a friend who has a Hasidic
friend who would be ready.
To give it to me and to trust
that I will not misuse this
book for, for some reasons.
Some groups have those books.
Some groups are too
small to have it.
If you have all your fellow
Hasidim in your smartphone,
there's no need to
have a telephone book
for it, obviously.
But still, I get to 44 of those.
Forty-four, if we know the,
roughly speaking 130
Hasidic groups today.
This is minority.
But if we realize this is 44
of 100 that covers all biggest
and mid-size groups, that
I did not miss any group.
That is larger than
the 1000 families.
Then the number of 44
comes to more than 90%
of Hasidic population worldwide.
And I managed to
process this data.
This data are very good
because they give city,
telephone number, of course.
Address and a zip code for
every Hasidic household.
And it's possible to have
every Hasidic household pinned
to the map for exact
location of this.
And what comes out of
this is, this is the map.
This is the list.
There are maps.
Most generally, the
number that comes
out of this is 129,000
Hasidic families worldwide.
If we accept sociology's
claiming
that every Hasidic household
today is 5.5 members.
It comes to a number of between
seven, too low or too high?
[Inaudible response]
No, it is because I,
I'm afraid you are thinking
about ultimate size
of the family.
And not the average size: 5.5
for a family includes families
that have all their
children out already.
Staying alone.
Or families who don't
have children yet.
Or families who just
start having children.
And families who at this moment
have all ten children at home.
If you take into average 5.5 is
a very reasonable estimation.
And it is proved
by counting of many
of those in small locations.
It's, it's not been done
on all Hasidic families,
but it's confirmed by a
representative samples.
So it comes to as I say 129
families, and between 700,
[inaudible] Hasidim worldwide.
Which in comparison
to the number
of [inaudible] Jewish
population comes
to the number of five percent.
The relative number
is five percent
of Jews worldwide
at Hasidim today.
Okay, and now I come to
now fifty-plus percent
in Galicia in late 19th century.
And now tell me whether five
percent is a lot of not.
I believe that, the, the, the,
the rumors about
Hasidic conquest
of world Jewry today
far premature.
It's, it's obviously
not a dominance.
And even more so if we
realize what's the nature
of the Hasidic settlement, the
structure of Hasidic settlement.
And if we realize that the
vast majority of Hasidism live
in close neighborhoods.
I mean, where dense
neighborhoods
of their population.
In so-called enclaves.
The term is not proper, but
like cities like [inaudible]
or Williamsburg or Borough Park.
Then we need to realize
even more so that
with those five percent
Hasidic presence is very strong
at some places.
But it's highly localized.
Outside of those
places, it's tiny.
It's almost nonexistent.
Those numbers when spread
into individual countries come
to United States
having around 42%.
Israel having around
48% of Hasidim.
And in both of those countries,
the Hasidim constitute
five percent.
The size of the square is the
size of the Hasidic community.
The color is the ratio,
is the percentage, right?
So yellow is five percent.
Deep yellow for United
Kingdom is ten percent.
Now many green small squares
which is small community
and very small percentage.
The only color that
sticks out is the red.
For 33% of population
being Hasidic.
And this is the, this is the
country in which you don't hear
about Hasidic conquest.
And this is Belgium.
Which is an outcome
of two factors.
On the one hand, there's huge
Hasidic settlement in Antwerp,
and on the other hand,
Belgium is a country
of very weak Hasidic
populations, 29,000 of,
of them only, altogether, right?
So this, this 10,000
oh Hasidim in,
in Antwerp make huge
proportion of, of Belgian Jews .
This numbers, because
as I was saying we know
which street they live.
Which zip code each family has.
And which rebbes they frequent.
It can go into much
deeper divisions.
So what we have here is the
next map is what are the
biggest settlements?
The biggest bubbles being
Williamsburg, Borough Park
on this side of the pond.
This is also [inaudible]
Crown Heights.
New Square, Spring Valley,
Lakewood, and other--
Miami, Los Angeles, and
Montreal, of course.
How could I miss it?
[Inaudible]
On the other side,
this is Jerusalem-- .
[ Foreign Language ]
This is what you get..
But what you get also
with the pie charts is
that you can divide how it
splits into individual groups.
And you can understand
dynamics of different groups.
You can compare it to
ideology of those groups.
And then you understand
why Satmar which is two
of three Hasidim in [inaudible].
And you go to Israel, and you
have very few Satmar Hasidim,
right?
And you see how they
are distributed.
And then you go into [inaudible]
and you go into [inaudible]
and you have no Satmar
Hasidim at all.
And you understand
it is connected
to the location of this place.
Behind or not behind
the green line
in occupied territories, right?
So it goes into division.
And allows us internal
hierarchies
of Hasidic politics there.
And you can come into numbers
with New York City having
26% of world Hasidim.
Jerusalem next.
Then Borough Park being part
of this New York City, right?
Williamsburg, Brooklyn,
[inaudible] and on, right?
Antwerp, you have almost 1800.
Montreal, 2000.
Coming back into this map.
This can be also divided
into individual groups.
That we know possibly to
surprise of some of you.
That [inaudible] is still
the dominant group today.
And i, I, I know the reason
for assuming [inaudible]
is dominant,
because they have the
biggest [inaudible].
They have the best visibility.
But it doesn't mean they
are the most numerous.
Of course you can claim
that Satmar is divided
into [inaudible]
so it's not 26,000.
You can divide them by 13,000.
So it is still below [inaudible]
but then you can say
[inaudible] is also divided
into [inaudible]
and [inaudible].
Well, we won't go
into the division.
Ger is not divided.
It's 12,000, right?
And Belz and all others.
So, so the, the maps
are presented.
They're, all maps and,
and the end tables.
And it can go, it can
also present, yeah.
I'm finishing right now.
It's, it can also present how
much individual groups are
divided into locations.
And how they compare
between themselves.
And whenever I have telephone
directories for then and now,
as sociologists like to say.
I have the map of Bobov
20 years ago and today.
And we can see how their
settlement is changing.
What is dynamic of those groups?
Over period of time?
And we can see where
[inaudible] are living.
So if you want to know where
to go for the [inaudible],
you get to chapter
eight for point four.
And you open it, and then you
can do Hasidic a la carte.
You can hop between
Hasidic Williamsburg, right?
Because you have
their locations.
And you can see how
[inaudible] is distributed.
And how it differs
between 1999 where the,
where [inaudible] houses
and where they are today.
And what is that,
what are the numbers.
And you can go even farther.
You can go also into culture
geography of Hasidism.
How do we know that this
[inaudible] Galician?
And what are we to say
for defining [inaudible]
Hasidim as Galician?
And on and on.
And how Jewish settlement was
divided-- no time to talk about.
An [inaudible] to talk about it.
Thank you very much.
Now is the time for questions.
And I very much hope you will
ask me challenging questions.
Should I direct?
And should people
speak to the mic?
[ Applause ]
>> Repeat the questions.
>> Marcin Wodzinski: Okay,
I will repeat the question.
>> So that it's on
the video, yes.
>> Marcin Wodzinski:
Yes, please?
[Inaudible response] I
can't hear you, sorry.
[ Inaudible ]
The question is about
possible correlation
between economical factor and
the move of Hasidic leadership.
From Russian territories,
Podolia and Volhynia westward
to Galicia and central Poland.
I don't think is such a factor.
Galicia at the time is the
poorest area of Austrian empire.
And the, proverbially poor area.
So this is not for
economic reasons.
And even more so, I want to,
to point to possible
misinterpretation
in your question.
Because you speak
about the move.
And I was speaking about
the movement itself.
But it's not people moving.
This is centers moving.
They disappear here
and appear there.
So it's not actual
people moving the place.
Leaders in Galicia die
and in Podolia die.
And there have no new leaders
appearing in their place.
While many more new
leaders appear
in Galicia, in central Poland.
So the movement is not of
actual people with their feet.
It is more movement of the
movement of Hasidism, right?
Yes, please.
>> I'm interested
in how many got out,
and how did they get out?
And how-- .
>> Marcin Wodzinski:
You mean the Holocaust?
>> I mean how come
there's any left?
Because the Nazis
deliberately came
to massacre these
little villages.
First with guns and trenches,
and then finally with -- .
I'm, I'm just amazed
that so many people--
how did they get out?
>> Marcin Wodzinski:
Okay, thank you.
Thank you for question.
The question I need to
repeat to the microphone is.
How did it happen that any
Hasidim survived the Holocaust?
And this is very good question.
Because it's very few
of them that they did.
Hasidim, we know very
little actually what was,
what was happening to Hasidims.
We had great research
about Hasidic thought
and the Holocaust.
And the leading scholar of
this issue sits with us here.
But I say together with this,
we know amazingly little
about actual faith of the
Hasidim during this time.
And this is something
that is more general.
Not only for Hasidism.
This is more general
scene of historiography.
That is tending to
abandon religious groups
and religious life.
And to ignore it,
especially for modern times.
I think we know too little about
what was happening to them.
We know, we can assume.
And we, we have some
anecdotal materials confirming
that as you were indicating.
Hasidim were very
often the first victim
of the Nazi oppressors because
they were the most visible.
If somebody was a Jewish doctor.
Dress, dressed in European
dress, speaking Polish
of Czech or whatever, Russian.
Living life of their
neighbors, it was very difficult
for German army to
recognize he's Jewish.
Maybe polish or Ukrainian or,
or Lithuanian neighbors
would help Germans eventually
with this.
But in the first stage,
it was not obvious.
The first Jew to be
approached and ridiculed
and massacred or killed.
Were obviously Hasidim because
they differed by the outfit.
By the, by the, by they,
how they looked like.
So this very clear.
Also, if you go farther.
You obviously understand
that for this well-educated
Jewish physician,
it was much easier to hide.
Because he had two
things to offer.
He looked like a gentile.
He know the language,
he knew the language.
He had Polish friends also
for whom he was a doctor.
And he had also something
to offer.
It was a good to have a
doctor in hiding, right?
Just in case.
And we have actually
testimonies of Hasid.
What could he offer?
A prayer. He knew no Polish.
He could not, even if he wanted
to pretend to be non-Jew.
He had no ways to do it.
Even he if he cut his
beard, changed the dress.
He would look Jewish because he
had no other ways of behavior.
He did not know nothing of
how it was to be [inaudible].
Because he spent far more of
his life within Hasidic world.
Than those incorporated people.
So obviously, very clearly
we have [inaudible] leading
to decimation of the Hasidim
during Second World War.
very few of them survived.
I have two maps.
I show one of them only.
That place of death
of the tzaddikim.
Which is showing 80 of them.
And there's another map
that I wrote of, to,
to survival of several
tzaddikim.
And on this map, I
mapped ten of them only.
And this I did on purpose,
to show this proportion
between those two.
But still, some of the
Hasidic leaders and some
of the Hasidim survived.
Some of them survived in camps.
Some of them survived
in Soviet Union.
Some of them found themself
in the Russian zone
when the war started.
And then because of
anti-religious policy
of Soviet Union, they
were expelled to Siberia.
And they were lucky to
be expelled to Siberia.
Because many of them
survived there.
In harsh conditions,
but they did.
And eventually they made it out.
There is beautiful
picture of Hasidic Jews
in [inaudible] in atlas there.
That's a surprising place
for them, but it happens.
So this is how they,
how they survived.
Those numbers were extremely
low after the Holocaust.
And there was quite a,
a common understanding
that Hasidic world
doesn't exist anymore.
It's mostly thanks to
demographical factors.
The fact that Hasidic families
are by nature more numerous.
They have more children.
Than non-Hasidic
Jewish families.
And the very conscious,
long-lasting educational
culture, spiritual guidance
from Hasidic leadership,
by those few who survived.
That they managed to
build communities.
And they provided safe haven to
those few Hasidim who survived.
And the first of them
would be Bobov rebbe.
Who [inaudible] the Bobov rebbe
died during the Holocaust,
but his son survived
quite miraculously.
You wanted to ask a question?
And then, and then I-- .
[ Inaudible ]
Thank you.
The question was if out
of Hasidism a la carte,
a new Hasidic movement?
Or semi-Hasidic movement
emerged?
No, the nature of Hasidism
a la carte is the lowering
of affiliation.
So not creating the movement.
Of course Hasidism a la
carte had huge influence
on creating neo-Hasidism
which is not a movement.
But it is a cultural phenomenon
very important from beginning
of the 20th century
and especially important
after the Holocaust.
Where many people
of non-religious communities
affiliate with some concept
or behaviors of Hasidic world.
And take it as inspiration.
And put it into new context.
Some Hasidic groups today are
also strongly inspired by this.
And [inaudible] being the most
visible expansion, ex-, ex-,
example of this development.
Which is taking forms of
kind of New Age religion
in some sections of Breslow.
So this is, so this
is phenomenal.
But I wouldn't speak about a
new movement that comes directly
from this Hasidism a la carte.
But I would say about
creation of the huge spectrum
of positions between
staunch Hasidic
and non-Hasidic identities.
Of people who are Hasidish,
semi-Hasidish, counter-Hasidim,
sometimes-Hasidim, ex-Hasidim.
But still respecting Hasidism.
And all those positions.
And as I just heard to--
today in the morning.
This group is growing today.
[ Inaudible ]
Early 1900s, you say, right?
There were many, well
Hasidim were under-represented
in immigrations from
late 19th century.
Because for many
Hasidic leaders,
United States was not the golden
[inaudible], the golden state.
It was a [inaudible],
the [inaudible].
Non-kosher country.
And this was for the
reason that United States
or America in general.
Was understood as secular place.
The place where you are supposed
to lose your traditional
Jewish identity.
Which was indeed the case.
Still many people from Hasidim
and of Hasidic origin
were coming
and were establishing their
Hasidic prayer houses.
And in Lower East Side,
this is the map for 1918.
There was a number of those.
It is still, they are
under-represented.
And it's very clear
that if you go deeper
into those Hasidic shtiebel,
there are how you say?
Ex-Hasidic.
They keep [inaudible]
they keep Hasidic prayer,
prayer tradition.
They keep tradition of
being from localities.
And having association
to a specific rebbe.
But they are not
behaving Hasidic anymore.
At the same time, they very
nicely-- I'll give you the,
the [inaudible] after
[inaudible] okay?
It's, on this map, you see
Hasidic shtiebel divided
in Lower East Side into those
who are in the eastern part.
And they are Hungarian
and Galician.
And those who are in the western
part, they are Polocian Russian.
So even on this side
of the pond,
they keep their distinctions.
Their [inaudible]
distinctions from the Old World.
So obviously they are, and
it's covered in the atlas.
[ Inaudible ]
For Satmar I don't know.
The question is how far it
is possible to map outreach
of Hasidic groups today or
after the war, more generally?
Especially for the
biggest groups
of [inaudible] and [inaudible].
For Satmar, I don't know
sources for this, unfortunately.
For [inaudible] it was
relatively easy thanks
to phone books again.
Because I found two of them
listing all [inaudible] houses.
Worldwide.
In 1999 and 2016.
And the deep blue is
the size of the number
of Hasidic houses
in given countries.
In 1999, and the
light-blue is 2016.
And you see how it changes.
In some countries,
like United Kingdom,
there's no growth at all.
In some countries, there
were no places before 1999.
You also see the color of
the country represents ratio.
The relative number
of [inaudible] houses
by the size of Jewish
population.
So the most intense colors you
have were Indo China, China,
Nigeria, surprising places.
I think that but also to an
extent, Kazakhstan, India,
[inaudible] it's
very strongly proved
that [inaudible] is strong
wherever Jews are weak.
As a community.
[Inaudible] is developing on
the peripheries of Jewish world.
They are conquering territories
where Hasidic, where,
where Jewish communities
are weak.
And this is actually something
that is exactly opposite
to the dominant Hasidic trend.
Because Hasidim today
[inaudible]
by all mean avoid places where,
which have weak Jewish presence.
For obvious reasons.
To be [inaudible] you need
a really good orthodox
[inaudible] infrastructure.
You need to have a butcher,
synagogue, [inaudible]
and you need to have this
butcher and that butcher.
You know, it goes
very, very deep into,
into establishing
structures for this reason.
The vast majority of
Hasidim live in metropolis.
In huge centers where you
have all this infrastructure.
And [inaudible] is
exactly the opposite.
And I think it is
fascinating about [inaudible].
Again, what you can read
from telephone books.
[ Inaudible ]
No, no. You have
individual households,
one, two, three, four.
Each of them has, you have
the first name, last name.
Place of the telephone
number, zip code.
Street, city.
And I had to read all of those.
By the name of the city and
to put it into the registry
under the name of the city.
And then to sum it up and
then I could have numbers.
Two thousand families
living in Montreal.
So that's how it goes.
There's no shortcut,
unfortunately.
There's no way to
do it, you know.
No, no, no, no, no.
Unfortunately, no.
Well, when it was an Excel file,
I could arrange it by the place,
and then to do the just sum up.
But for all other books.
And actually those books
are not arranged by place.
But [inaudible] I had
to read line by line.
Satmar book is that size,
600 pages or something.
And I had to read
it line by line.
Fascinating read.
[Laughter]
I think that's right.
This right?
Thank you very much.